Welcome back, Master!
Hello everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome!
Welcome in!
No!
Rice nut!
Stop!
I think people think it's serious.
Stop it, please!
Hello everybody.
Goat men-nasai.
Goat men.
Happy birthday!
So fast.
We'll do a quick birthday song before we continue.
Ooh, J-Rag, thank you so much for the birthday gift.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, goat men-nasai!
Happy birthday!
Welcome everybody to Dredge.
Dredge.
What does the hat say?
Should I make it bigger?
Women fear me, fish fear me, men turn their eyes away from me.
As I walk, no beast dare make a sound.
In my presence, I am alone on this barren earth.
Nice.
That's what my hat says.
Hopefully I'm not blocking.
I'll move around if I'm blocking anything, you know.
I heard you weren't graduating, Mint.
Yeah, you heard the real truth.
Lots of people don't graduate.
It doesn't make you any less smart.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Excuse me.
Am I a joke to you?
I graduated clown college.
Probably.
Thank you so much for the birthday gift, dude.
Thank you.
Killer whale.
Yeah, look at that.
Look at me with the little clown wig.
It's not a wig.
It was a phase.
That's an actual self-portrait.
I went to one of those department stores and got a nice little picture of me.
To commemorate graduating clown college.
It's like I can still hear her.
What was the clown name?
Lil' Minky.
Obviously.
Yeah.
Lil' Minky.
Yeah, obviously.
And it's a very versatile name.
It can work as a lot of things.
Like people are saying it's a good rap name.
Well, it was my rap name.
It's my government name.
It's my clown name.
It's... yeah.
It's a lot of things.
Yeah, my government name.
Lil' Minky.
Minky.
Yeah, first name Lil'.
Last name Minky.
Yeah.
Middle name is...
Crazy.
Lil' Crazy Minky.
You know, I don't want to scare anybody off.
When they first meet me.
If I'm just like, hey, I'm Lil' Crazy Minky.
They'll be like, woah, woah, woah, buddy.
Woah, woah.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Your rap name is MCMF?
That sounds wrong.
Wait, I don't get it.
I don't get it.
Lil' C Minky.
MC...
MF?
Like I'm an MC?
MC?
Like I'm intro...
Introducing?
Introdu...
No, I almost said it again.
Introducing the show?
Like I'm talking at the show?
MC Minky.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Guys, we're playing dredge today.
Um...
I have seen...
That other people have played this.
And I have thought, I want to play this too.
Because it looks like...
Up my type...
Up my alley.
And I was like, oh, but I won't watch.
That's always such a frustrating thing, no?
When I see a game and I'm like, I wanna play this.
I...
Won't watch it, but then I'm just like...
But I wanna watch Marushi's play game.
It's so good, isn't it?
Zero, thank you so much for the 5k.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Me with Outer Wilds.
Everybody says not to...
Watch Outer Wilds.
But to experience Outer Wilds.
But I still think you can watch it.
I don't know.
Can I get a feel better beam?
James!
Oh, my voice.
Feel better...
Beam!
Feel better.
Outer Wilds is better to watch...
After you play.
I guess I get that.
But I was happy.
There were some people that were just like, oh...
You know...
Streamers playing Outer Wilds...
Like when they get to the end, it doesn't hit the same...
To the streamer.
But I still feel like it did.
I don't know, I guess it depends on the person.
Maybe it depends on the person.
I should say.
I just remembered.
Friday, I have to change the time of...
Devil May Cry.
It will probably be...
A few hours early.
Maybe.
So, I will...
I will post that later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I will post that later, later, later.
I'm not rowdating.
No!
So, yeah.
I meant to say it the other day.
And I forgot.
But, yeah.
Yeah.
It will be like a midday stream for me.
So, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
I meant to say it.
Yeah, exactly.
Thank you for loving us, Minto.
You...
You saw nothing.
Hi Minto.
Hello Unreal Citizen.
Hello.
Too late!
Let's play the game.
Let's play some dredge.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's dredging the depths.
Yo-ho, yo-ho, yo-ho, yo-ho, yo-ho.
Job listing.
Angler wanted.
Was that me?
Oh sorry.
Yo-ho, yo-ho.
Yo-ho, yo-ho, yo-ho.
I hope that's not me!
That's my ship!
Oh no!
I look rough.
What kind of bait would you use to catch wisps?
A little bit of this.
A little bit of...
The morning light fills your eyes and you try to sit upright.
You're lying on the cold wet dock where you collapsed the night before.
Oh!
A short man is shouting orders at a handful of workers disembarking from a boat nearby.
The man notices you.
It worked!
I died.
Ah.
Ah, well, welcome to Greater Marrow.
I must say, quite the dramatic first impression.
I see you've already introduced yourself to the jagged rocks along the bay.
Did you not see the lighthouse that was shining bright at you?
Ah, well, I'm glad to see our new fisherman upright and breathing.
A birthday!
Wait, hold on.
This game is one of those, see, like, you can see my mouse.
I can't escape, so I can't scroll up.
Hold on.
What if I do this?
Ah, I'm free!
Thank you guys!
Ducky, thanks for the five gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I missed my birthday song, Cash, and it was early in this month.
Oh!
I got you, Junto.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Junto.
Happy birthday!
Can I get an amen?
Amen!
Alright.
Your boat was hopelessly damaged.
But I've had a few of the locals move your things to one of our old vessels.
We'll catch up later to discuss more details.
I'll let you get out there to catch some fish.
I think I need to see a doctor.
I think I need to catch some Zs.
I slept on the dock.
Mayor, please!
Give me at least one day to settle in, no?
Walk it off?
I'm so... I'm so... I'm so strong.
It's 6 AM!
See if you can fill your cargo while you get your bearings in the life.
Finally, I don't suppose I need to say this, but get back by sundown before the fog rolls in.
Keep a close eye on the time.
It can really creep up on you.
It's 6 AM.
What are these torturous working hours?
Working from 9 to 9.
Wish you the best in your future.
My future is here!
I'm not graduating!
I can't tell if you're joking or not anymore.
No!
Almost died from drowning, but you're still coming in, right?
Of course, boss.
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna... What's tab?
This is our...
Okay, hold on.
Let me figure out where I should hang out here.
Maybe I just shrink myself.
My hat is in the way.
If I'm like here, does this seem like a decent spot to be in?
Do you think I'll be blocking much?
It's like I'm swimming.
I'm the fishy.
Maybe.
We'll see.
We'll figure it out as the game goes on.
My cabin.
I have pursuits.
Catch fish for the day.
Met the mayor of Great Marrow who sent me out to catch some fish and find my bearings.
Seems nice enough.
Warned me to get back before nightfall though.
Said something about fog.
A bit dramatic.
Alright, alright, alright.
We have a map.
Devil's spine.
I'm going that way.
We got some messages.
Nobody loves us.
Okey-dokey.
Move forward with Waseda.
Music's a little loud.
Here we go!
So when I move, the time advances?
That's crazy.
Is this one piece?
Yo-ho.
Give it up for Luffy.
Rotate with this and just hide with...
Wait, I don't see the height changing.
Oh, I think just like going up and down.
Just kidding.
Okay, I think this is a fishing spot!
We're gonna start fishing!
I'm too good.
I got a blue mackerel.
Wow.
I kind of...
I think because of Keep Driving, if you haven't watched me play that game.
It's like... It's driving roguelike.
Like sort of RPG.
But because of that, I've been like, I kind of want to play like inventory management stuff all of a sudden, you know?
Well, what time is sundown?
I guess it tells us, huh?
Disturbed water.
Oh, I got a cod.
Been wanting to... Yeah.
We're gonna put him right there.
When the sun is down.
Makes sense to me.
Anyways, guys, today is... Wednesday?
Is Wednesday, my dudes?
Is it?
Maybe not for... Oh.
Shallow.
You don't have the right equipment.
Oh, man.
Happy midweek, everybody.
Everybody?
This is so calm.
This is so chill.
Oh, we got another blue mackerel.
Hump day!
That's what my dog used to do.
Wait, is this another town?
Ahoy, neighbors!
Wait.
What's that over there?
You guys see that shiny?
I'm going beyond.
Time only advances when you're moving, fishing, or taking other specific actions.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Shipwreck?
I'm dredging.
Oh.
I can't dredge.
What does dredge mean?
I thought it was like a play on dread.
Oops.
It's a message!
It's a message in a bottle.
Collect.
Oh, there's more over there.
Yo-ho.
Wait, this looks like a damaged ship.
It's not my ship, right?
That would be pretty unfortunate.
Lure bottles.
Removing stuff off the sea floor.
I see.
Oh, I can't dredge.
No.
But this sunken ship is so mysterious.
Let's see.
What do we got here?
It's also a cooking term for covering in batter.
Yummy.
I can't dredge here either.
Give me some fish.
Over there.
I see some.
Oh, right here.
Right here.
I'm fishing.
I'm too good.
Wait, what do I hear?
Dolphin?
Those are big.
Those are whales.
Not dolphins.
Whales?
This place has such a rich ecosystem.
That wasn't me.
I don't believe you.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I'm starting to get...
I think we need to go home.
Hot dog.
Indeed.
I'm a gamer.
It's fine.
Is it?
Toggle lights by E.
Light up the night.
Helps you see but makes you more visible.
What is that?
That's kind of scary.
I don't like that.
That's kind of spooky.
What do you mean I'm more visible?
To what?
To the people.
I did...
What does that mean?
What's that?
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, never mind.
It's totally still there.
Wait, my light is on, right?
I can't tell.
Toggle...
Oh, with right click.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, just kidding.
We're fine.
I don't need it on.
What's that sound?
Increases my panic.
Bright lights and sleep will reduce it.
What am I panicking for?
Look, there's fish right here.
This is fine.
There's fish right here.
You hear something?
No.
We're night fishing now.
Oh, uh...
Arrow squid.
Nice.
What's this?
Oh, I gotta get this repaired.
Okay.
More squid.
How late can I go?
Can I just fish until my heart is content?
Keep watch on my eye meter.
Is it so bad right now?
What is that over there?
Look, we're like in the...
in the little inner coastal spot.
What?
What's going on?
I think I'm panicking.
Um, hello?
Don't hurt the ship, please.
How do I dock?
Oh, F.
I made it!
Yes, but watch your sanity.
I can't really tell when it's going low.
I just see my eyeball going freaky.
You step onto the dock at Greater Marrow.
I keep wanting to say...
Minnow.
I like small, cozy little towns like this.
You also like losing your sanity.
The mayor is waiting nearby.
Ah, I've seen you returned in one...
Oh, it is one piece!
Before you head off to town, we should discuss the matter of your boat.
As I mentioned earlier, your old boat was too badly damaged to repair.
However, I'm more than happy to sell you that replacement vessel, yours to own.
It's real.
It's real!
Oh my god.
The official dredge stream from Maiden Minnow.
I can't get any...
better...
than this!
What do you mean?
Are you seeing things?
I'm not seeing anything!
Actually, I truly am not seeing anything.
I kinda wanna see something spooky.
Something will happen.
We'll make it.
I understand you may not have the necessary funds on hand, so we'll consider it a loan.
But I wanna make this easy for you.
Until your debt is repaid, a tiny portion of your fish sales will go towards paying it off.
A small amount of interest will go towards improving the town.
Wait...
So you're splitting it three ways?
You're...
You're gonna take...
some for the boat...
and then some for the town.
And then...
I get the...
What a scam.
What if I was just like, nah, I don't wanna be a fisherman anymore.
I'm just gonna chill here now.
How much is a small amount?
Can we talk percent, please?
Thank you so much, TV's brand, for the five gets a thank you.
So to recap, you'll need to sell fish to the local market, paying off your debt, and in turn keeping the population fed and satisfied.
Understand?
Where do I sell the fish?
Our local fish...
Our lotion.
Our local fishmonger, he's covered in lotion.
He's like...
You can just see this guy like...
He's like walking up to you.
Like, you know how when you put on a bunch of sunscreen?
Or rather, old sunscreen, right?
And it had like that white, like super goopy white texture.
He's just covered in that.
You can't even see his face.
No wonder he's so slippery.
Fill with praise and purchase what you catch.
He's open all hours.
Off you go, then.
Sell those fish while they're still fresh.
Okay.
Oh.
Ew.
You enter a squalid shack on the fringe of the marketplace.
The familiar smell of fish...
I'm trying.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
It rubs the lotion on its skin.
Not the hearts.
The familiar smell of fish fills the air.
That's like a tongue twister, no?
So much... So much alliteration.
Flies buzz haphazardly around the downcast man behind the counter.
Surprised they found a new one so fast.
What happened to the other one?
Hey, it takes a certain type of person to last out here.
It's not a life for everyone.
Anyway, to business.
I'll pay you for fish.
Bigger and fresher means more money.
Some species are just worth more, too.
Ghost goes minted?
Other towns on other islands might pay you different.
While you've still got a debt outstanding here, I'd suggest you work on paying it off first.
My special fish!
So let's see what you've got.
Alright, I've got this guy.
Sell.
How much are you... $12!
Nice, nice.
Sell.
What if, like, as I'm standing here, they're depreciating in value?
How much debt do I owe?
Oh wait, there's a sell all fish.
We doing numbers.
Oh yeah.
Bye, fish!
Nice.
Is that it?
The mayor is standing outside the fishmonger's store.
Excellent work.
I have no doubt you'll be able to provide for this town.
Look here.
I found this down by the docks.
I'm sure someone like you could make something out of it.
Why don't you take it?
Ooh, research pod.
Oh, one last thing.
Our local shipwright mentioned she might be able to make some modifications to your ship.
You should pay her a visit.
Is this guy stalking us?
For real?
As you walk into the yard, you see the shipwright making...
Sorry.
Making repairs to a damaged hull.
She looks at you briefly before turning back to her work.
Oh, complete the introduction quest.
You must be the new fisherman.
I can make improvements to your vessel in the yard.
Mind you, I'm not in the business of doing favors around here.
Payment is up front and everything takes time to install.
Also, if you take any damage from the rocks...
Damage?
Couldn't be me.
I would never.
No, ma'am.
You have my fisherman's vow.
I'll never damage my sweep.
Now, yeah, a rock might attack me.
That would not be my fault.
You know?
Any damage at all, I can patch it up.
Mostly.
She shrugs and gestures towards the hull she's currently attempting to repair.
A number of wooden boards, all well above the waterline, are splintered and scratched.
Take a look around.
Just remember, the bigger the equipment, the longer it takes to install.
So plan ahead.
Wait, so we can even get better...
My current thing is coastal, but we could get shallow stuff.
I only have 80 bucks.
Daniel, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much!
We also got better motors.
Maybe I should have done a better job fishing.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
These are so expensive.
We need some investigation at a dock first.
Can she look at this stuff for me?
I think I have to come back.
Well, we can repair this.
Repair all.
Okay.
I at least repaired that.
Boat goes minted.
Oh look, we only have 35 dollars remaining.
We're actually killing it.
And then we also got our special message.
We had a slight accident yesterday around the shallows at the back of Greater Morrow.
A rock seemingly... See, that's what I'm talking about!
A rock seemingly appeared out of nowhere and struck the front of the boat.
See?
The rocks do attack.
It did not penetrate the hull, but it jostled us around, and a few items fell overboard into the water.
We did not see what they were, which is of some concern.
But we believe all important articles are accounted for.
He has been checking over some notes from the boat renaming ceremony.
He is paranoid that he performed the steps incorrectly.
I've never known him to be so superstitious.
Who's he?
I love my hat.
Thanks.
Thank you for the 50 yen.
Thank you.
Boo's Pro Shops.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Encyclopedia.
So we're gonna wanna save up some money so we can get things that are not just coastal fishies.
I guess we sleep.
This is also making me wanna play Dave the Diver.
Alrighty.
Back on the ground.
Back on the ground, back on the ground.
We're gonna go...
Right over here.
Wait, what's that?
A floating buoy.
Buoy!
Did you finish Dave the Diver?
I did, actually.
But there's been so many DLC.
For Dave the Diver, it's kind of insane.
It serves to mark safe passage past dangerous rocks and obscured hazards.
Its dim light also provides a brief respite in the gloom of the night.
The music is so relaxing.
What the heck.
I'm fishing.
Just kidding.
Yeah, there was Godzilla DLC.
Okay, I need to learn my lesson about what's shallow waters and not, you know.
This is not shallow waters.
Okay.
But we get, like, better fish if we wait until night.
Yeah, the Yakuza DLC!
What if we just fish over and over again?
Until...
Thank you for the Akasuba!
Hold on, hold on.
Token of appreciation.
I don't watch a lot of live streams because I work a lot, but I do watch a lot of clips.
Thank you!
I wanted to stop and say thank you for all your hard work.
Many hours spent entertaining everyone, thank you!
Quiet time, thank you!
Really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Good luck with work!
Welcome back.
Thanks!
Molly!
Molly, I missed your... I don't know, I'm so sorry.
It's your birthday.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Molly!
Happy birthday!
Sorry I missed it.
I'm Muramasa because I'm a ghost on a ship?
So true!
Not Muramasa, Murasa.
Where am I?
Where's home?
That's home.
I got a little twisted for a second.
These are the twisty fish.
Twisty.
Twist them around.
Get it twisted.
No, don't!
Sorry.
Sorry, fish.
Look, they're like... they're spooning.
Gone fishing.
This is the realest I've ever gone fishing.
Gone fishing Rio.
Not clickbait.
Can I get this one or is it too shallow, I wonder.
This one doesn't look too shallow.
Wait, these look big over there, no?
Those look like some big old...
What?
No, I think this is the...
Yeah, this is just a mackerel.
Hold on, let's go over here.
Where are these big guys?
Some big ones right here.
What was that sound?
Hello?
Oceanic.
I can't get it yet.
Dang it.
Oh, there's a message.
Sharks.
I collected it.
OK, I guess we just gotta save up.
Dang it.
I'm ready to explore, papa.
Please, I'm not a child anymore.
Please, papa.
Let me explore the ocean blue.
But we do want to save also.
OK, it's starting to get dark.
Nice.
We want to save a little bit so that...
Or rather some room so when we get to the spooky things, right?
Which we're almost there.
Can we sell these fish and come back later?
Oh, I didn't think about that.
Probably?
Am I safe in here?
Am I safe?
Yet another graduation joke.
Let's see.
Hopefully we didn't just waste our night, you know?
I've had a special order come through from a customer.
If you can fulfill it, I'll pay you above normal prices.
Tell me about the order.
One gold flounder and one grey eel.
Alright, you'll need to have a rod that can handle shallow water.
Shipwright should be able to sort that out for me.
OK, we got to sell our fish.
101 dollars.
You're always safe when you're docked.
Alright.
Return to town.
Undock!
OK.
It's just a little night.
Look, we're like right here.
If I just...
If I just fish right here, we'll always know which way home is.
It's all lit up and bright.
OK, we got some squid.
Oh, depleted.
That's so sad.
Uh...
Assophobia.
What does that mean?
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh, what's my...
Wait, it's...
I do it and then...
Oh, right click.
That's right.
Hello, fish!
Can I still see home?
OK, we can still see home.
We're OK.
Fish!
Glub glub.
I can still see home.
We're OK.
Glub glub.
Fish here?
Oh, my light went out.
Maybe I should go home.
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
I'm going home.
I'm going home!
I'm scared.
Oh, it's the rocks that appear out of nowhere.
Oh, it's the rocks that attack.
That's what comes out?
No, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
We're docking.
What was that?
I'm docked.
I'm docked!
Why are you here?
I've come to fish.
There's nothing here for someone like you anymore.
Do yourself a favor and move on.
She turns and shuffles back along the path that leads to the light.
I got one squid.
Sell that guy.
Some is better than none, right?
Now we should be able to buy...
150.
OK.
Catch is shallow.
40% We should be good with a better one.
How do I do the research?
Fish fear me.
I fear fish.
Our mutual antipathy prevents us from finding inner peace.
Gear icon at the dock.
Oh, OK.
Thank you.
Alright.
I will do that.
Let's see.
Let's buy this, though.
Rotate.
Nevermind.
Oh, I have to put it in here.
OK.
Hello?
Ah, there we go.
OK.
Installing.
Gear icon.
Research.
What does this do?
Oh!
Flexible.
I should have maybe not bought the new rod.
Wisp monger.
How much for one fellow wisp?
Live and learn?
I'm literally dead.
Everyone does that?
Glad to know that.
Everybody... Well, you know what?
Then I'm gonna do this one.
Rather than this one.
We'll do this one.
So we can now get the oceanic fish, too.
So we got the shallow, we got the oceanic, we got...
Wait, do I have to pay for that?
Oh, it's really expensive.
OK.
Interesting.
Alright.
Undock time.
Let's go.
Oh, I forgot to also look at my...
My messages.
Morning of the second day of the honeymoon.
Mare ignored.
Wait, was he there?
Oops.
Sorry, Mare.
And our first day proper.
Mare wants to speak with you.
OK.
Today we're sailing around the islands and inlets at the back of Great Mara.
I love the rocks here.
The layers and colors are so striking.
Furthermore, the fishing is relatively poor in these shallows.
So I know he will keep his hands on the wheel instead of the rods.
This man can't stop gripping his rods.
He renamed the boat last night.
Julie.
He did a fancy renaming ceremony and everything.
I think he took that more seriously than the wedding.
Supposedly, it's very important to perform it correctly, lest you want ill fortune to follow the vessel.
He wanted to throw away everything with the old name on it.
But I kept the keychain Ocean... Oh, keychain.
Ocean's Riches was a good name.
I wonder if that's why the boat was cursed.
You're not supposed to keep anything with the old name.
I think he has prepared a surprise picnic lunch.
I can see the basket half hidden, stuffed under a blanket at the front of the cabin.
I love it when he tries to be romantic.
And then we gotta get the flounder eel.
Let's go into shallow stuff.
Am I gonna die by thunderstorm?
Lightning?
Did you sleep?
I did.
I did, I did.
What is this thing?
I was gonna say this looks like a flounder.
Let's just deplete this area, I guess.
They're kinda big though.
It's bigger than I anticipated.
Fish.
Oh, I just noticed the stock too.
Gosh, okay.
I gotta pay more attention.
I had a freaking heart attack checking Twitter today.
I'm sorry.
I'm apologizing even though I didn't even do anything.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I didn't even do anything.
Oh, the music in this game is so nice.
Is this a shallow spot?
No, it's a coastal spot.
How did it all start anyway?
I don't know.
I saw... Oh, the eel!
Nice.
Oh, he's kinda big.
I think I need to go sell.
I saw... I saw Lewood comment.
And that's how I saw it start.
But apparently it started before that.
I think somebody retweeted it.
So, essentially for those who don't know...
Somebody retweeted my graduation announcement from 2021.
So...
If you see people saying...
Oh, I can't believe Minto is graduating.
I'm not!
And now I'm getting messages from people who are just like...
Oh, you're graduating?
Oh my gosh.
Please don't go.
But I'm not.
Let's go to the fish.
You got fish for that order?
Yes.
Just leave whatever you have here.
I'll keep the order on ice until it's all ready to go.
You...
Hands me... Oh nice.
Good, good.
I should be pleased with these.
I've got another order here.
This one is a little more curious.
They want a couple of squid and a whole black grouper.
I don't think I've gotten that yet.
Don't go Minto!
But yeah, everything is fine!
Please!
I was like, should I delete the old post?
But it's my history.
I can't delete it.
It's my history.
Twitter be trying to cause population control through wisp heart attacks?
No!
Someone is going to get mad at me.
I feel it.
They're going to be like, I can't believe she would joke about that.
Graduation jokes are the worst.
I can't believe she would, she would, she would toy with my feelings.
Please, it's a reminder we would miss you.
I can still hear her voice.
Hello!
It's like way less dramatic than I thought it would be.
I'm back!
Hello!
It's the Minto of your future!
I have come to say...
Say...
Follow the five second rule!
After you drop the pickles...
You will get sex...
There you go.
Anyway, don't see many people fishing squids these days.
They only feed at night.
And well, you know what nights are like around here.
Good luck!
Do I?
Alright, we're selling all the fish.
Okay.
How much debt do I have left?
Only ten dollars remaining!
Nice!
Nice, nice.
Tell everyone that tweets you about graduation that their message convinced you to stay.
You know, yeah.
Your message convinced me.
Thank you.
Thank you, Twitter user.
Where was the... Oh, here he is.
That's the person I was hoping to see.
Will you be sailing out east towards Little Merrill?
Would you give this package to the dock worker?
Oh, okay.
I got a small package.
The mayor hands you a small damp package bound in string.
It's dripping slightly.
Should we look up...
Real squid fishing?
The dock worker will pay you upon delivery.
Please be quick about it.
I don't want it to spoil.
Oh, okay.
Alright, to the east!
To the east, to the east.
Okay, to the east.
To the east.
We're heading north.
So I need to go...
Wait.
No.
I'm heading east.
I thought the...
I thought the actual little spinny thing would point to the direction.
Not...
Not the compass itself.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, straight line.
All the way across.
We're gonna get paid, so it's worth it, I think.
Okay.
This is correct, right?
Hello.
What?
A delivery?
Let's see here.
He tears a small hole in the paper and peeks inside.
You can't say for sure, but it feels as though he's shielding it from your view.
It's human meat.
Yeah, nice and fresh.
This'll do nicely.
I'm to pay you, I suppose.
25 bucks.
I was given this old book a few weeks back, but it didn't make much sense to me.
You'll surely get more use out of it.
A book.
The number of pages are folded over.
This too is a Strand-type game.
Keep it in your cabin.
Perhaps you can read it while you're on the water.
Stop by for a chat any time.
You know how lonely it can be.
Wait, I can sleep here?
Traitor.
You enter a brightly lit shop.
It's packed with antiques.
The shelves are full of jewelry and other baobles.
Baobles!
An old man peers at you over silver spectacles.
Is that...?
No.
I don't believe we've met.
Forgive me, my eyes aren't what they used to be.
Baobles.
I specialize in antiques and jewelry.
I'll purchase any special trinkets you happen to have.
Have you got anything nice with you today, perhaps?
No.
I got nothing.
I'm poor.
Let's get a few more fish.
Then we'll head home.
Right?
We're almost out of debt.
It's so important.
Alright, we got a car.
Alright.
Oh, depleted already?
The sundown feels so ominous here.
Sounds like a plan.
It is a plan.
I'm the man with the plan.
I'm the ghost.
Is it already night?
The squids are out.
Oh yeah.
The little... What's it called?
The eyeballs out.
But what's in the water here at night?
What if I just fish?
And I don't leave.
Will something still get me?
The spot is depleted.
It's starting to get dark.
9PM.
What's this shiny over there?
What happens in these waters?
Only one way to find out.
Oh no!
I lost an eel!
I couldn't turn!
That rock came out of nowhere!
What?
That rock came out of nowhere.
That was craziness.
Did you guys see that?
These rocks do be attacking.
Oh, yes I do?
What did I get?
Oh no, I lost one.
He'll have it on ice.
I need to get this black grouper.
It's a shallow guy.
Regular business.
Sell all fish.
We did it!
I'm seeing things, I am.
You actually do be attacking.
The mayor is walking quickly towards you.
He seems to be in a good mood.
With a spring in his step.
Fantastic news.
Thanks partly to your efforts, Greater Maru is growing.
Our town is sure to be swarming with visitors any day now.
In fact, I've granted a consent for the shipwright to expand her facilities.
The old dry dock is operational again.
Yeah, we paid off Tom Nook.
We're homeowners now.
This is the best fishing sim.
No, I'm sorry I scared you.
I missed the other one and the goodbye.
I was at work when I found out.
I'm sorry.
Please have fun and enjoy the rest of the day.
I've also allocated some money to improve the fishmonger's services.
He might have something to talk to you about soon.
Keep up the good work.
We're glad you've chosen to be here with us.
Lucky dry dock.
Juliet, we can make significant improvements to your vessel here.
We're talking extra space.
More attachment points for equipment and even superior hulls.
I wish I still had time to say...
Say what?
Say... Say whaaaaat?
Say whaaaaat?
We need a decent stock of hard materials for these projects.
Lumber, metal scraps...
It's time to dredge!
How do I get materials?
There's plenty of decent materials around the coast from various shipwrecks and the like.
I'm sure you'll find a way to get at them.
Materials assigned towards upgrades here will be stored.
So don't worry if you only have half of what we need.
Whoa!
Okay.
Let's save that for another time.
I want to save up for...
I want to save up for this hydraulic rod.
But I guess we also need to learn how to dredge.
Anything... What's the engines like?
Mine is also old and rusty.
Oh, I have a peculiar engine.
These are rusty engines.
We could get another engine.
This is the nets.
These are lights.
Cloudy lens.
These are so expensive!
You can get multiple engines.
Yeah, yeah, that's what I was just looking at because there's another slot right here.
We could get it.
And we can go pretty fast.
Okay, I'm going to get it and I'm also going to repair.
Install.
I'm going to repair our ship.
Okay.
Two engines, baby!
We are so fast.
We are so strong.
What else did I get?
Oh, the book.
That's right.
Sustainable fishing.
Read to unlock.
Selected as active book.
Time passed.
Passed time to read.
Okay, cool.
Let's go to sleep.
We'll read in our dreams.
It's me listening to my audio books at night.
And we're off!
Let's go try and find that...
Oh my gosh, it already feels like we're faster.
Let's go try and find that group.
What are we trying to get, actually?
Hold on, there's some stuff over here.
This looks...
I'm drifting.
What is this?
Oh no, wait, is this dredging?
I can't do it yet.
Squid and grouper.
Yes.
These are oceanic, right?
Wait, what do you mean I don't have the right equipment?
Oh, I didn't buy it.
I knew that.
Maybe he's like a night time guy.
In the shallow areas.
I just got unlucky before.
Music in this game is some of my fave.
It's so nice.
It's very chill.
Despite how...
I guess spooky this game kind of is.
Hmm.
Maybe we fish close and we wait for night.
And we sell and then we come back.
The water.
It's so deep sounding.
Oh, what?
I feel like I hit that.
Everything in this game is totally vanilla.
Yeah.
The spooky rocks.
I saw one spooky rock.
I wasn't scared even a little bit.
Let's just get some stuff.
Make some money.
Actually, we keep everything that we make now, which is great.
Yay!
Special fish.
Let's just go sell it.
Okay.
What's that kanji?
I can't read.
Futo what?
Sorry, my kanji is so bad.
Actually stupid.
Yippee!
Futomomo.
Sorry.
It's not because I couldn't read it on the tiny monitor or anything.
So many fish are being caught.
Yippee!
That was the real catch.
Gulp.
Futomomo, I love you.
I think everybody here would agree, right?
Everybody loves size here.
Tiny monitor doesn't support kanji.
My brain doesn't support kanji.
We're undocking.
We're gonna...
Am I playing the game right, you guys?
Is this how you're supposed to play the game?
Am I doing alright?
There's like no shallow...
Wait, this part is sparkly over here.
I wanted to see it before too.
I get in.
Oh, inspect?
No, wrong way.
Eyes are better than booba?
Hey, hey, hey.
We're not waging war here.
A lighthouse towers above.
Waves crash endlessly against the perilous rocks below.
All creatures, human or otherwise, would have their brittle bodies broken and thrown at its feet.
You ponder the intrinsic power of this structure.
A vast column of stone, shouldering the responsibility of countless lives.
How long will it stand?
How long until it decays into ruin?
Its purpose exhausted.
The lighthouse towers above.
We're getting real philosophical out here.
I have like not a lot of fishing spots.
Maybe more will spawn at night.
Hopefully.
The ocean does that to ya.
I guess so.
Depleted.
There is literally nothing here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I see fish!
We got the black grouper!
There is DLC for this game too, right?
Depleted.
Turn around?
How do I turn around?
Reverse, reverse!
Drift!
I would keep going.
It's not that I'm scared or anything.
I would obviously... I wanna see what that is.
I would obviously keep going.
It's just that, you know, like...
I don't have any room left in my thing.
In my inventory.
Fishing would be totally pointless.
Yeah, it's not that I'm scared.
It's just that the fishing would be, you know, pointless.
Still go back out?
Yeah, but I have like these things to do.
I do need another squid.
Come back when you have everything.
Okay, I found this book.
I got another book.
Let's go.
Hey, why is my chat freezing?
Freezing.
F5?
Why is it not working?
We are frozen.
It's cold.
Oh, there it is.
I think.
Ah, there we go.
What if I undock?
What if I keep going?
We gotta get the eel.
He's just in another shallow area.
Like right over here.
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so good.
What's that?
I think I should leave.
Nevermind.
I don't have to get the eel.
I'm leaving!
There was... You know what?
There was an attempt.
Okay everybody?
I gotta get my beauty rest even.
How much money do I have?
79% complete.
Nice.
Nah, we'll do this one first.
I have 200 dollars.
So not quite.
Now we have to wait until night time again.
We have to keep waiting until night.
I want to go beyond.
I want to go beyond these waters.
I want to see the world.
These other islands.
Back to the ground.
What if I go beyond?
Break the boundaries in due time.
I'm not a kid anymore papa.
Please let me go.
Let me go out and explore the world.
Is that another boat over there?
Maybe it's a shipwreck like we saw before.
Corrupted scales and bulbous eyes like nothing you've ever seen before.
What the hell is that?
I didn't know that was possible.
Sustainable fishing.
What if we go to this island over here?
Do you think we can make it?
Can I like... Oh see, I think that's a dock over there, no?
What's over here?
It gets freaky.
It's gonna get freakier.
I'm so excited.
So excited for the freaky.
What are we doing here?
Steel point.
Oh, I can't do anything.
Just kidding.
Okay, well at least we know we have a place to sleep.
If we need it.
All the way out yonder.
What's that over there?
Looks like another town maybe?
I also want to know what that bright light thing is in the...
Now I have so many questions!
Free cam.
It's just like a little rest point.
I don't... Can I fish here or is this considered ocean?
Coastal.
We can fish.
Oh, my bad.
Oh!
Wholeseeing god!
Staring outwards, unblinking eyes borrowed from a larger being.
But not the mind to process what it sees?
Please?
Is this normal?
Am I gonna start getting only weirdo fish?
Depleted.
Alright.
Do I have enough... I think I have enough space for the eel.
We just need to make sure it's shallow water.
Which I don't see... Oh, wait.
No, that's not shallow.
What do I do?
Why can't I get the fish that I need?
This game is...
Oh, wait.
No, just kidding.
It's the squid.
I'm silly.
I needed this guy.
Yay!
Now we're good.
Can't just call them weirdo fish.
They're doing their best.
My bad.
Squid, squid, squid.
Yay!
I was thinking the eel in the shallow.
Okay, we're good.
Alright.
I love freaky hags.
The ghost spirits.
Hey, all ghost spirits.
Yes.
Alright.
84 bucks.
Let's go.
Fishmonger wraps up the fish and hands you some money.
I didn't think you had it in you.
Night fishing is a tall order.
Good meaning to talk to you about a new business venture I've been considering.
Crab pots.
I've got one here for you.
In fact, it's a little banged up, but you could get it fixed at the shipwright.
Deploy a crab pot.
Don't forget where you put it.
Just drop it out at the sea anywhere, then come back after a day or two to check on it.
Passive income.
Mr. Crabs.
Canny time.
I've got a customer after a fiddler crab.
And a common crab.
I think if it's a common crab, he can definitely get it himself.
Both species can be found around here.
What is it today?
You hand the grotesque fish to the fishmonger.
He grins, raising the fish up to his face before inhaling a deep, stuttering breath.
Now this is the sort of specimen to liven up my day, I wonder.
Planet Mike.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Uncommon common crab.
He runs his fingers firmly along the length of the fish, as though feeling for something.
He pushes from one side of its stomach, and a small shape can be seen against the bulging scales.
He slices the fish open.
From its stomach, he pulls a small piece of fabric and spreads it on the counter.
It's a delicately patterned handkerchief.
Well, I've never seen that before in all my days.
I'll give you this.
And I'll pay you for the fish, too, of course.
Yeah, you better.
Too hot for you, too.
This is how handkerchiefs are harvested.
It's not the first corrupted fish I've seen in these parts.
So if you find more before too long, I'll pay you well if you find...
Oh, we can buy more of the crab pots.
I have one.
This guy.
He sells for 45 bucks.
Nice.
Oh, we're so close.
I think.
He wants to get the crabs.
We're having crab tonight.
Crab legs on the house.
I'll treat you, right?
I'll go... I'll go... I'll go... I'll go out fishing and I'll get you crab legs for you to eat.
If that's what you want, baby girl.
If you want crab legs, I'll go out and fish it myself.
I'll harvest them myself.
Sometimes they might be a little grotesque.
But I know you wouldn't mind.
Just, you know, be sure to chew properly because you might bite into a handkerchief.
I'm allergic?
Well, I would serve it if I was attempting to assassinate you.
Which I'm not.
But I mean, if you ever wanted to be with a ghost, it would probably be easier if you were a ghost.
But luckily, that's not the case with Minto.
Fumbled.
Someone's eyeing me from their window.
His face is mostly in shadow.
I know what you took to the fishmonger.
And I'll be clear.
I know he extracted an artifact from it.
I need to inspect it, but not here.
Meet me on Blackstone Isle.
Head out this bay and cut south.
I have a business proposition that you'll want to hear.
I'll be waiting.
South.
Okay, we gotta go south.
But...
Wait, what do you mean my equipment?
Oh, this?
Oh, it's only $7.50.
Oh, we can buy this!
But I have to sell something else.
Maybe we sell this rod.
And then buy this simple skin.
But then I don't have a coastal rod.
You can put the rod in storage.
Oh, I can?
Uninstall.
Oh, storage.
Wait.
It won't let me go to storage.
Oh, to storage I press both.
Wait, middle?
What did I just do?
Okay, okay, I did it.
I did it!
Alright, we're gonna buy this.
The big bad boy.
Nice.
Fisherman!
Have you run into a photographer on your travels?
She docked here a few days ago for supplies.
I suggested that she take some pictures of the town for promotional purposes, but she didn't seem too interested.
She mentioned she was heading south.
Oh, that's where I'm going.
After some Z's.
Back.
Oh, my...
Wait, what's this?
When did I get this?
Dredge.
Cod.
Oh, it tells me what the fish are.
When did I get this?
I just... I see, I see.
I always had it.
That's so funny.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Okay.
This is south.
Yup, I figured.
Many people don't see it.
That's where we're heading to.
I think.
But first, we're gonna fish.
Our first time fishing in the ocean.
We got a bronze whaler.
That's like the most expensive thing you could get.
Probably.
We've got... What else is out here?
Oh, this is coastal.
Nevermind.
I leave you for bigger adventures.
This probably is coastal too.
You see a fellow fishing ship, be sure to honk.
Really?
Okay.
Is that proper etiquette?
Honk at your neighbors?
Workshop.
The workshop looks as though it hasn't been used in decades.
We'll go in here first.
It's a threat.
Honk if you're haunted.
Honk if you love Minto.
Maybe I should make some bumper stickers.
Honk honk.
Honk if you love Minto or if you breathe air.
I do not do the second one.
The man is standing in a doorway, watching you approach.
He's holding an old book in one hand.
It's bound in crimson with silver ribbons.
Suddenly gravity falls up in the air.
You came.
Good.
Allow me to introduce myself.
I am a collector of many things.
Art and artifacts.
Treasures and truths.
And curi-curios that occupy the periphery of desire.
And you have something for me.
You give the handkerchief to the collector.
He holds it up to the flickering light and studies it.
These patterns are unmistakable, even after all this time.
This handkerchief comes from an old ship I've been searching for.
It sank many years ago.
Every second spent breathing air is a second spent not honking because you love Minto.
Reject breathing!
No!
You can breathe and honk at the same time.
Just like that.
Honk!
Okay, I give up.
You proved it.
Does breathing strip me away from becoming a ghost?
No!
I mean, well technically, but like, you know.
Don't become a ghost!
Don't become a ghost.
That means that you have unfinished business.
That's so sad.
Wait, hold on, sorry.
I don't know why YouTube chat is being a little stinky today.
I carried items of great importance.
As you can imagine, retrieving them is proving to be challenging.
That's where you come in.
She called us stinky.
Not you!
YouTube.
It's YouTube, as always.
My proposition is this.
I will outfit your vessel with equipment that will let you dredge the wrecks and dark depths.
Find me these lost relics and I will reward you in ways beyond all imagining.
You need not give up your fishing career.
I'll merely need a few hours with your vessel to make the necessary alterations.
I accept.
An excellent decision.
I'll prepare the equipment immediately.
Just tinkering with my boat.
The relics we're looking for are a ring, a necklace, a watch, a music box, and a key.
Wait, so I don't find these in the fish?
Passes out from honk.
No, don't honk!
Breathe!
Maybe it was an advanced technique.
I'm so sorry for...
Very advanced technique to you guys.
I would encourage you to ask around the towns about shipwrecks or other strange occurrences.
Anything that might be worth investigating.
Return when you have something.
And what's in the workshop?
It's locked.
Mysterious.
Mysterious, mysterious.
Alright, let's go dredge.
We're dredging, we're dredging, we're dredging.
Nevermind.
I thought this was the deep water.
Pay money to get in the... Oh, the workshop is DLC?
I see, I see, I see.
What are we helling out?
My business is to support my ocean color queue and that work is never done.
Stop!
Let's dredge.
Wait, press F to change length.
Avoid gaps!
Okay, I have to read...
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
Good wisps listen.
We're traversing.
Okay, I'm dredging.
Nice, I got some wood.
Ah, we can use that for upgrade stuff.
For real?
Wait, these look cute.
What are they?
I don't have a shallow.
Dang it.
No!
I'm gonna sleep at this dock.
I'm not loyal to one city.
She ends the stream.
No!
Grieving father?
I'm sorry.
Hello, is everything okay?
Do you know of any shipwrecks around here?
He's like physically crying.
Hello, sir.
Bad wisps live on in legends.
What is that saying?
Oh...
Women who follow rules don't make history.
That does not apply to you guys.
Do you want us to listen or to tell you the truth?
Tell me the truth.
I can take it.
Well, yes.
You see, my only son was lost at sea some years ago.
He's still out there somewhere.
In one of those wrecks.
All alone in the cold, dark water.
What if he's alive and married to a mermaid?
Minto cute.
That's the truth.
You lie!
Papa, you lie!
The man is clearly trying his hardest to remain composed, but tremors of grief wrack his body.
Truth is Minto cute.
You lie!
I was wondering.
I noticed you have some dredging equipment installed on your vessel.
If we were able to retrieve any of his belongings from the wreck, I'd think he'd feel more at peace if his mementos were with me.
He wore a bronze belt buckle, specially engraved.
I'd recognize it anywhere.
If there's a chance you could find it, I'd be in your debt.
Minto is cute.
Stop!
Any strange occurrences?
I don't get out a lot anymore.
So I don't see much of what goes on.
But I do remember the old mayor in his final days.
What an awful sight it was.
Screaming and throwing things into the sea.
Throw it back!
He would cry over and over.
Begging anyone who would listen.
Howling it to the wind.
These days I almost feel like I understand.
Anything else?
Nah.
Alright, what are you guys saying?
What are you guys saying?
Especially when she's...
I'm not!
Let's sleep here.
Throw it back.
We're throwing it back, baby.
Okay, so we got a ring.
I wanna dredge.
I wanna dredge a lot of stuff.
I wanna...
In the deep sea.
I wanna fish.
We're gonna do lots of stuff.
We're like...
We've unlocked the whole game basically at this point.
That was so close.
I forgot to sell my whale.
Let's go sell him.
One of the cutest.
Stop it, please!
That's also material.
Jesus.
There is no one here.
Dang it.
We'll never stop.
My crabs!
My crabs are ready!
Look, they're bustling.
I have a common crab.
I'll leave the pot there for some more time.
I am a common wisp.
Yeah, I got some crabs.
One...
That's the fiddler crab!
Holy moly.
Regular business.
Wait, this guy only sells for...
Oh, he's rotting!
You guys, I messed up.
I messed up!
No!
Oh my gosh.
We're such a hot commodity.
I waited too long.
I didn't realize.
Correct engine operation.
That's right, I have books.
Let's put these...
I'm gonna put these in storage for now.
I'm getting overwhelmed.
Oh, I can store stuff here.
Maybe we do...
More rod space.
Is what we'll work on, maybe.
I don't know.
I'm not forgetting Tab.
But I did forget Tab, yeah.
I did.
Let's see.
What is this one about?
Correct engine operation.
Rods, reels, and ropes.
Eh, we'll just read that one.
I'm gonna come back to these guys.
I wanna go fishing first.
And dredging.
Always have a book selected.
Yeah, I forgot about it.
That's my bad.
So there is two places I want to go to.
One is here, because this is a deep ocean.
This is an oceanic, I remember.
I couldn't fish here before.
I got an...
Okay, we're gonna see this reel amount.
Wait, there's more?
There we go.
Nice, nice.
Start fishing.
We got another, boys.
Nice.
I don't think I can fit another...
Can I?
Fish Tetris.
Maybe.
We're too good.
We're too good!
Alright.
Then, I remember there was a ship on the other side of that island that I wanna go dredge.
Back it up, back it up.
Back it up.
Oh, I don't have the dessert water.
Why does it sound so ominous?
She said the title.
She's saying the title.
So far, I'm so relaxed.
I feel like I could play this game for like 10 hours.
You know what I mean?
I feel like I played...
$100 each!
Almost!
Well, this guy is a little...
You know, he's smaller but he's a bit of a runt.
Do it.
We're rich!
We're so rich!
Let's do the builder.
It's peaceful.
This game reminds me of a game called...
I don't know why I can't hear donuts.
I just realized.
Like the sound isn't playing.
I don't hear it either.
Thank you so much for the 50 yen!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
This one of mine earlier...
I'm so sorry!
Oh, I see it.
Are you a wisp monger?
Oh wait, no, I've read that one.
Oh wait, this one.
Step one, sleep during the day.
Step two, fish at night.
Step three, question mark, question mark, question mark.
Step four, profit!
This game reminds me of a game called Nantucket.
It's a whaling roguelike and is loosely based on Moby Dick.
Fun.
It's got to be damn sight better than this bloody town.
I think I just need to get away for a while.
Maybe not come back.
Going backwards is a mistake, don't you think?
You should always keep moving forward.
Moving along.
I can't go back.
What if we like roleplay our snake?
She's gazing out to the sea again.
Lost in thought.
Say, if you find some materials, maybe you can help me move.
I mean really move.
There's an island I've heard of.
Steel Point to the north.
Two units of lumber and two units of scrap is all I need.
I can make a new place for myself out there.
You'd be welcome to visit too.
Just stack it up at Steel Point when you have anything.
I'll pay you when the job's done.
Snake the fisherman.
Jay, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
What do you think is the best bait to catch a maid?
Specifically of the phantom kind.
Hopefully mint colored.
You think I would fall so easily for just a measly bait?
If I were to be caught... Oh, I don't know if you're talking about me.
But if you were to try and catch a ghost of the phantom variety that is mint colored...
I would suggest... I would suggest anything with a flashy light lure.
You know?
Did the stream go down?
Stream dead?
It's fine here.
Maybe refresh.
Refresh, refresh.
Let's see what the lighthouse keeper has to say.
What is it?
Do you know of any shipwrecks around here?
She eyes you suspiciously.
There's a spot near the back of Greater Miro where the current carries in wreckage from the sea.
Some nights you can see a natural glow rising from the patch of dark water.
I can't imagine what's down there in the deep.
So if you're looking for what I think you're looking for, it's best to just move on.
Stream fine for you.
Yeah, it might be regional issues, but it seems like so many people are saying that it's an issue.
I think it's an NA thing.
It's not on my end.
For sure.
It's not on my end for sure.
Santiago, thank you so much for the five gift, thank you!
South US and lacked.
JP fine.
Thank you.
Sorry guys.
Maybe try and remember where you saw... where you last left.
You can come back during the VOD or something.
Have you heard of any strange things happening?
I see plenty of strange things from atop the lighthouse.
Sometimes I don't know whether I can trust my own eyes.
She holds the lantern up so that it shines brightly into your face.
Are you really standing here in front of me?
Or is it just another of the fox tricks?
Hot dog donut test.
Hot dog working.
Charm Quark, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
YouTube please, all I did was tell the truth.
The truth cannot be handled.
Who lives on Blackstone Isle?
I see a lot from up here, you know.
I saw that ill-fated boat return.
I chose to look the other way.
I watched in a natural glow flicker through those windows.
Whatever you've got planned, I hope you know what you're doing out there.
I don't know actually.
What do you know about the old mayor of Little Morrow?
That's... he's... I try not to think about him.
It's a painful memory for us all.
Some nights I still think I can hear the hum of his engine sailing past the bay.
But I know he's gone and I don't want to talk about it anymore.
Okay, I should go.
I should get out of here.
We have so many... so many... okay.
We need a fiddler crab.
We need a belt buckle.
We need the relics.
Neagle!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
We back?
Yippee!
Install some headlights for night fishing.
We should do that.
They're kind of expensive and they're not very good.
Let's see.
What's our current... oh we have like no light.
These are the same.
We'll get the $180 one.
Alright.
Wait, so if I right click...
I see, I see.
So it does...
It does.
It does its thing.
Is this still catching fish or...
Or checkpot?
Needs repair!
Oh.
I guess we'll grab you.
Let's do a little bit of fishing before we go in.
I don't have the right equipment.
Okay.
No worries.
Now that I have a light I feel so less scared.
I don't know if that's a good thing or not.
I don't have the shallow.
Okay, just kidding.
Go into the dark sea.
Will I die?
Wait, what's that glowing over there?
You see that?
See that glowing out yonder?
What is that?
Go check it out.
I hope I don't die.
Okay.
Oh, that's a rock.
Wait, wait, wait!
What's happening?
Oh, hear a foghorn echo.
I think I'm about to get attacked.
I think I messed up!
No sir, it was a friendly...
It was a friendly gesture.
It was a greeting.
Greetings!
Hello!
I think I'm in trouble.
Oh gosh, there's rocks.
Oh he's still out there.
Wait, is that him?
Dang it.
Who told me to honk?
But I wanted to see what the shiny was.
I wanted to see what the shiny was.
So sad.
Man...
I haven't died yet.
I guess you...
Oh well.
Seems very much like you will be able to die in this game.
So...
Alright, let's put our crab pot...
What if we...
Put it like more in the ocean.
Plenty of crab, plenty of crab.
I don't know if the bigger crab needs like a...
Like more depth, you know?
Maybe like 9 meters?
Right here.
Alrighty.
I'm never equipping my horn ever again.
Honk honk.
Wait.
Is this deep water or coastal water?
I can't tell.
Coastal.
Why do you hate honk?
Honk to us.
Stop it right now.
What did we learn there?
Honk is bigger than our oshi.
No!
Not even.
A little?
Alright, I know there's a shipwreck over here.
We're gonna go check it out.
Right there!
Look look look look look, it's even shiny.
What if this is the guy's son?
He was like right next door.
Go for a sail around the edge of the whole island.
Neat stuff can be found in nooks and crannies.
That's what I'm trying to do.
We'll go to the other side.
Okay, dredge.
Star dredge.
Oh, shoot!
Ah, shoot!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, the guy's son really did just die on the other side of the island.
Wait, I was kidding!
No way!
He was right here!
A little tragic maybe.
Why is that funny?
I'm a nervous laugher.
Okay.
I laugh at everything.
Please understand.
Please.
There we go.
Oh, this is still coastal?
Ah, whatever.
Part of me doesn't want to press F.
You know, I want to press like...
I want to press like space instead.
Uh oh.
What should I do?
You can change the settings.
True.
We got a shark!
Okay, good.
We almost there.
We weren't able to fit our shark.
Let's see if we can get another one.
If I'm good!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm going home, I'm going home, I'm going home.
What is that?
Oh wait, that's my crab.
Which I will check another day.
Once we upgrade a little bit more, we'll go over to that, you know.
We just got an axe.
Let's see if we have...
Okay, nice!
We can read our other book.
No crab cakes tonight.
Book finished.
Yeah, got it.
Thank you.
And our map is all that.
Encyclopedia...
Pursuits.
We got to return the belt buckle.
And we... I need to find scrap.
Okay.
These are 122 each.
Let's go.
Heck yeah!
Net time?
Right now?
Should I go check it?
I might get hit by rocks, but I guess it might be okay.
It's not even midnight.
What should I...
I guess we could... Oh no.
I don't really have much else that I can buy.
That I don't already have.
And then with this...
I don't have anything.
Upgrade the rod.
Rod.
Oh yeah, I got... Oh!
Like this!
How do I get research parts though?
Use parts to research new equipment.
Click on things in the dry menu.
Dry drop menu.
So if I'm like this...
I can't purchase it.
I get them from dredging.
Yeah, I know that.
Oh!
Wait, the research...
The research parts too I get from dredging?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
No, no, I'm not...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
These...
Those things... These I'm using for the quest.
I don't want to use it for...
I don't want to use it for the upgrades just yet.
Binto is my favorite fisherman.
Thanks, Mio.
Let's check on our crab.
Like here... Is this dredging?
No.
Don't do that!
Please.
It doesn't seem that we have any crabs.
I'm heading home.
I'm scared.
No rocks, please.
Honk?
I already did that.
Okay.
You ever think how mint sounds like?
What are you gonna say, Ophelia?
Little Tommy Pickles.
It's one of my favorite games.
And seeing one of my favorite streamers play is a double treat.
Thanks, Everkin!
Alright.
Did I get it?
I sold everything.
We're going to sleep.
Honk shoo, honk shoo, honk shoo, honk shoo.
Okay, let's go check our crabs.
And we'll explore around...
Why is this fancy?
What is this?
Wait, wait, wait.
How do I... It's fancy, it's fancy.
What do I do?
I need my shallow rod.
Thank yous out.
Kinda sound like the guy who plays Steve.
In the Minecraft movie.
Jack Black.
Oh, what does he say?
Flint and steel.
How do I... Wait.
To cargo.
Okay, so wait.
I need to store this first.
I wish I could get rid of this.
Uninstall.
Store.
Take.
I just realized it takes time.
Oh no, will it be gone?
My shiny, please.
Oh, it's still there, it's still there.
Oh, and we have crabs.
We got crabs!
Okay.
Oops, my bad.
A barbed eel.
So the shiny is...
A special guy.
Still a common crab.
Lame.
Alright, let's check around the island a little bit.
Need to see a doctor about that.
Really?
Is it that dangerous?
Curved?
We got to get the curved fish?
The music is so ominous.
What's over here?
Shiny.
All that's left of this boat is an old husk.
You pull a little closer.
We got a ring!
We've got research board!
We've got old iron chain!
Nice.
Okay.
Good stuff, good stuff.
For a Lovecraft inspired game, it's really relaxing.
Alright!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you so much!
Wood?
Oh, there was wood?
Okay, I'll go back.
Sorry, I didn't notice it.
The stone hums quietly, sending ripples through the air around it.
Faint shapes dance upon its surface, vanishing before your eyes...
Before your eyes can focus on them.
The cold stone does not respond to my touch.
I've got to...oh, sorry.
I've got a cold touch.
I'm a little worried about the time.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, I see the wood.
I can't believe I was so blind.
I need to go insane first.
Really?
I'm not already?
I'm scared.
I'm scared of being out at night.
It's right there.
Will I die?
I'm dredging for a keyblade?
Oh shit!
I'm not very good at this, huh?
This thing is huge!
An abnormally large and heavy key cast from an unfamiliar metal.
I need to leave.
I need to go.
I think it's time for me to go.
Don't honk back.
I'm gonna go over here and sleep.
I'm gonna go to this part and sleep.
Keep going!
My ship!
What is that?
Wait, did I lose anything when I got damaged?
I didn't check.
No!
We lost our special fish!
Aw man.
That sucks.
I lost the research part too!
My eel.
My special eel.
But I can take the key to him.
Show me.
You hand him the key.
The cold metal shimmers a strange shine as he holds it.
The shape of the key, the teeth, the head.
Now somehow it seems changed.
Smaller.
Has it always been this way?
Is this all?
Where's the lock?
I'm working on it!
The collector grows agitated.
It seems the pieces we're looking for have traveled further than I anticipated.
Much further, I suspect.
It sucks in the early game.
Aw yeah yeah.
In that case, allow me to aid in your travels.
He turns a few pages in the book and mutters something low under his breath.
A burst of light fills your vision and you stagger back briefly.
Otherworldly speed at a price.
Now go, we have more relics to uncover.
Am I the bad guy?
My intuition tells me that the current may have carried some debris to the southeast, towards Gale Cliffs.
Make that your priority.
I'll mark a location on your map where you can begin your search.
Anything else?
The words you read from that book, what did they do to me?
The book holds power from the deep.
I merely extended its power toward you.
Is there one in particular you wish to know more about?
The bad guy?
No, we're not the bad guy.
There's no way.
I'm innocent through my innocence.
Obviously.
Arriving to Minto Streams with otherworldly speed.
The words of haste are instant and cruel.
They will impart a terrible speed to your vessel.
Be warned, however, it may put a great deal of stress on your engines.
I'll ask him later.
We'll talk later.
There is the thing right here.
Should I even try to get it?
What if I put my stuff in storage?
Someone said put all your things in storage.
If I do that, will I not lose them?
Go store your stuff and go get the thing?
Okay, let's go get it.
Hold on.
Why is YouTube so bad?
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I feel like I'm always complaining about the chat freezing.
I feel like I'm always like, I care, everything freezes on my end.
Luckily I can still read through OBS, but it's frustrating.
I wonder if maybe I should start using a different browser.
Put us in the microwave.
Yes, I'm gonna fix YouTube.
It's me.
I use Firefox right now, but the chat is always freezing all the time.
Alright, let's go.
It's like right here.
Or is it right there?
Yes.
What if I die?
Wait, it seems kind of far away.
Where is it?
Is this real?
I think I got duped.
I think I'm crazy.
I think I got...
I think I got bamboozled.
Oopsie!
Oh my gosh, it's already 4 AM.
Time for our 2 hour rest.
The red fog makes you go crazy.
Oh, I thought it was an item.
Ouch!
What's one more... What's one more thing that we gotta...
That we gotta fix, huh?
Whoa, what?
Oh.
It's like a water spout.
Try out the haste.
Should I?
I don't even feel like I'm going that fast.
Uh oh, my ship is on fire.
About the belt buckle.
You explain that you found a belt buckle, but it's currently in your sto...
Oh, sorry, it's in my storage.
My storage.
Well...
Yeah.
Well, it only hurts something wide...
I'm getting all messed up.
How do I get to my storage?
Oh, here it is.
And we can maybe sell...
We can maybe sell...
Sorry, it looks so...
I don't know what I'm thinking.
We can sell these.
And maybe this?
Okay, alright.
Grieving Father.
About the belt buckle.
Yes, you give the belt buckle to the man.
This is... this is his.
Oh, thank you, bless you.
You've returned him to me.
Please, take this.
I'm not... any money to pay you.
But this might hold value.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay, and the trader...
Sell all trinkets.
There we go.
Alright.
Store.
Yeah, we'll store that.
I've learned my lesson.
And let's go check our...
Crabs.
Alright.
Money, money, money.
Oh gosh, seriously?
I
need to put it in a different spot.
I don't need curved fish.
That is exactly what I was just about to search for.
Some curved fish, baby.
Oh wait, we can use this.
There's curved fish!
Oh my
gosh, why am I so silly?
I'm so silly.
Please.
Wow, how many do you think they need in there?
Oh my gosh, we can do even more?
Nice.
We need lots of curved fish.
We should probably go do that right now.
We should go do that.
To the shrine!
Should we be out in the sea on such a bad storm?
Be careful not to crash.
Hey, hey, don't jinx me.
The music sounds so scary here.
Curved fish.
Oh, is this like a puzzle?
I've figured... I've learned your puzzle.
Can I store this?
I stored it.
What does it do?
Clashing of bone and sinew?
I was thinking that too.
Metal gear?
A little bit?
Okay, let's go home.
Don't crash.
Oh, I say, it's just a buoy.
I didn't make any money, but...
Oh well.
Don't crash.
I can't see!
Drift!
Yo, I'm too good.
That reel is worth a lot.
Is it any good?
Like, should I use it?
I was so close.
Not even a little.
What are you talking about?
I was not even...
I can turn in my sleep.
It's both shallow and coastal.
It's huge!
Oh, it's you.
Who were you expecting?
Your engine, it sounds like...
I'm sorry, I mistook it for the vessel of an old friend.
Dejected, she turns and walks back towards the lighthouse.
Is it because our engine is busted?
Please repair my ship.
Thank you!
So this is coastal and shallow.
Shallow.
Please install.
Nice.
Yeah, we can get rid of this one too.
So uninstall.
Store.
Now...
We can do everything!
Yeah!
Now we can do everything!
No questions.
What, to the lady?
She just left.
Was there something?
I think we're good.
Toss the crab in the storage.
I think I should sell him.
Or rather, my storage.
I think I have some crabs in the storage.
Oh no, he's running!
And I'm gonna use the research.
Yes.
But I don't have that guy, so...
Done.
Okay, sell my fish.
I get 5 bucks.
My rotting crab.
And we're going to research.
And we're going to...
What the heck are...
Oh my gosh, this gets so intense.
Mangrove?
Volcanic?
This is...
Abyssal?
Are these spoilers?
What?
Oh no.
I see.
It's okay.
We have to unlock this anyway to get to these, so...
Lava fish.
Get other tabs.
What are you talking about?
Like these?
Oh wait, hold on.
Sorry.
I wasted it.
And then we lost the other one.
Can I get it back pretty please?
Rookie move.
I am a rookie.
Hold on.
We gotta get that scrap.
Let's see.
We need the fiddler crab.
Alright, so we got...
We found the key and that's it.
Okay.
Our map.
Steel Point.
I like the...
Oh, that's where our...
Oh, okay, okay.
Got it.
So I'm assuming...
Wait, do we have to go there at night or...
There is scrap by Steel Point.
Got it.
Thank you.
I'm assuming we have to go at night, no?
I will go check.
No?
A night vision...
Oh, sorry.
I was reading chat.
It's a good thing it was just a buoy.
Oh my gosh, I just repaired my ship.
Pay attention Minto, what's your problem?
Alright, now we can fish at our own leisure.
Yeah!
One hour.
Oh my gosh, we got him!
I'm gonna go give it right now.
I don't want to waste time.
Let's just go.
Hold on, let me check my map again.
Yeah, I'm on the right way.
But I'm gonna storm.
Storm room.
It's gonna spoil.
Don't let the...
Okay, okay, you guys are right.
I don't want it to spoil.
You're right, you're right, you're right, you're right, you're right.
You're right, you're right.
Still rots in storage.
Okay, we'll go give it now.
I think I saw ViviCorp.
For the gifted.
Thank you!
It's okay.
Take it.
Yeah, I got your crabs.
I got your crabs.
Alright.
Hands you some money.
These will do.
Glad you got to use...
Some use out of that old pot.
You can always buy more here.
Repair damaged ones at the shipyard.
I have one final request for you.
As you've seen, some fish around here can develop odd deformities.
What do you think happens to a person that eats the flesh of one of these mutants?
They go mad.
Well, perhaps.
But I want to know for sure.
He's going to poison the people.
What?
Bring me a mutant fish.
Any will do.
Just keep this between the two of us.
I would have had one for you, but...
Unfortunately...
I...
I got attacked by a killer rock.
Actually, no.
I got attacked by an actual fish.
I got attacked by a killer fish.
Gekko!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Is this a coastal?
Yeah.
We don't need any more.
Wait.
Can we still give...
Give perved fish?
The bent fish?
Little fish?
No?
One and done?
Okay.
Sad.
Alrighty.
We are looking...
For a thing.
Around here.
And we can sleep here, so that's not so bad, I feel.
Is that it right here?
I think...
Oh, it's a shipwreck.
I think so.
I think we...
I think...
We found this...
Wood!
Wood.
Depleted.
It's already so late?
Excuse me?
At least wood doesn't...
Doesn't die.
A goblet.
Can I...
Can I put you in storage?
No.
Harry.
Did you put your name in the goblet of fire?
Do we see any mysterious...
I think that's it over there, maybe.
But first we sleep.
Thank you Mint for being...
What did I do?
This is the island where the builder wants materials.
I forgot.
This is where she wants it.
We sleep.
Wow, we were so rested.
Probably the first in a long time.
Nice.
Is this it?
Is this a dredge?
Dredge!
This is...
Something fascinating!
I hope I'm not stressing you guys out with this.
Why is it sometimes I can store in my...
Why sometimes I can store in my storage but sometimes I can't?
Storage is only when docked.
Okay.
Wakari Master.
Scrap!
Scrap.
There's more.
Do I have more...
I can make space.
We can Tetris this.
I'm a natural now.
I play keep driving.
Maybe I'm not a natural.
But I can do another one.
lol
Well, we can definitely put some of these on the island.
Yeah!
I didn't know that.
That's actually why I wanted to play it.
I was like, whoa, that's so spooky.
You know?
Storage and island.
Alright.
You...
And you.
She's gonna...
She's literally gonna Tony Stark it.
She's building her house with a box of scraps.
And...
She will probably...
Wait, see?
No, it's still not...
I'm docked but it's not letting me put it in storage.
In a cave.
No, on an island.
Okay.
So it's gotta be...
I understand, I understand.
Let's go home.
Sorry, I'm playing it a little bit safe right now.
I'm playing it a little bit safe.
Not cause I'm scared.
But because...
Better be safe than sorry.
Why can I hear donuts now?
Even a bird on high dies a glutton's death as do the fish of the deep.
The fish that belong to a family called the deeps died from overfeeding and so did a bird that got...
Octagon?
Mayling?
Okay.
We talked to the builder.
Let's get moving.
Oh, I'm bringing you along.
Okay.
That's...
That's new to me.
Okay.
I didn't expect that.
I'm gonna put her in storage.
Okay, we put her in storage.
Actually though, we have some stuff.
So let's see if we can dry dock something.
Oh, I see.
Like I only need one cloth.
Oh, see.
I think we can do this.
Oops.
I think we can do this actually.
You and you.
Yeah!
We got the upgrade.
Not exactly cruise liner conditions.
She can live.
She'll live.
Modifies one cargo space to also hold lights.
Okay.
I think we'll do...
the engine maybe next.
What do I have left?
We have wood.
Wait, I think...
Was anything like two wood and then a cloth?
Two cloth and one wood.
One wood, two scrap.
Okay.
No.
Gosh, we're just like...
We're just a little bit off.
That's okay though.
We'll get it easily.
And we can go sell this goblet and sell this lady.
I wish I got more books.
There's no storage at Steel Peak though.
That's okay.
There might be once we have her.
Once we put her in.
Thank you.
Uh, that's my name.
Don't wear it out.
Alrighty.
I don't think there's so much...
Wait, can I...
I can't get it yet though.
Oh, I already bought it.
No!
I didn't mean to.
Okay, we'll go for the spotlight thing next.
Can I refund?
Press F?
Oh.
It's like half the money though that I spent.
That's okay.
We'll just keep it in storage.
We'll use it eventually.
It's too late.
Oh, so if I were to make a mistake...
I could...
Do F immediately.
Something, something.
I'm dead, but I still live and learn.
I don't know another expression that counts for ghosts of the same variety.
If you don't put it in storage.
Okay.
But like I said, we're still gonna use it, so...
It could have been worse.
07 money.
My money.
Wait, is this...
This looks like a dredging location.
Everybody prepare to dredge.
Ooh.
Pearl earrings.
How fancy.
Oh, I think I just realized what you meant that we don't have...
We don't have storage on the island.
Because I put the lady in storage.
You were like, Mito, you don't have storage on the island.
And I was like, it's okay.
I don't need anything.
Okay, we'll have to go back home.
Oh no!
No way.
Put him in storage?
No!
I can't Tetris myself out of this.
Will the earrings?
How?
It won't let me.
Place on the left?
Oh, I see what you mean.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
There's something shiny over here.
Alright, we're gonna have to go retrieve our little lady.
A once strong wooden hole lays broken against the shoreline.
The stern is completely beached.
Try to get inside the stern.
You pull a bit closer and manage to clamber into the back of the wreck.
You look around.
Stuff.
I can't take the scrap, but we'll come back for it.
We shall return.
For now, let's go sell our wares.
And wonders.
Thanks for streaming.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Wait, I think it went so fast and it's your name.
Aventurine!
Thank you.
And I can get our lady out of storage on this island.
Everything's a win, right?
Yeah, Minto.
You're playing the game correctly.
Thanks chat.
Sell all trinkets.
Okay, nice.
And since we are here, I'm going to use it on the engine.
Now we can go buy the better engine.
I probably could have unlocked the other thing, but it's fine.
We need a better engine, I think.
Dredge is one of my favorite games ever.
I hope you're enjoying it.
I am!
I'm having so much fun.
Oh, I can't let our little lady friend out yet.
That's okay.
We undocked and we head over to our other place.
Did I have any...
One moment please.
The goblet!
I knew I had something to sell.
I was like, I knew I had something to sell.
Harry Potter would be so sad right now to know his favorite goblet is gone.
More money!
Alright lady, I know, sorry, it's taken us two days to take you to the island.
But it's really hard work, okay?
You gotta understand.
How much money is this new engine?
These are probably fresh.
They are fresh.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I have a peculiar engine and then...
Yeah!
How much faster is this?
15!
Okay!
New engine!
I like how when you sell something it just goes back into the inventory.
Alright, let's see.
We're zooming.
Alright, rise and shine lady.
I need you out of my inventory, out of my storage.
And we're set in sail!
Okay!
What a beautiful morning.
Good morning Mito!
The music almost seems like Minecraft-esque sometimes, you know?
I'm gonna fish right here.
What if we get a spooky fish?
It's morning!
Morning!
Wake up!
How silly.
Minecraft is a horror game and this isn't.
So true.
Mito cute.
Search.
Yes, yes this will do.
Thank you fella.
Give me a short while to get things built here.
You're welcome back anytime.
She reaches into her toolbox and pulls out a handful of components.
Take these.
Always good to have...
Two!
I thought she would only give me one!
It's only at 10 AM so I'm still gonna search around this island a little bit.
This was scrap I think, right?
Metal scrap.
All depleted.
Maybe this is it.
Are you guys sure I don't have to get it at night?
I'm sure feeling that way.
Get what?
The cursed item.
It's not here, but it was so shown on the map.
Must drop the scrap.
My scrap!
The map was marking the quest for you.
Oh, you think it was that?
Ewww.
My scrap!
Drop the fish?
Yeah.
Goodbye fish.
You live another day.
Wait, hold on then.
Oh, you're right.
Hold on.
Gale cliffs.
Where is that?
Here!
All the way!
OK.
I learned.
SOS!
Are they OK?
I'm saved!
Saved!
Oh, you were a sight for these sore eyes.
What happened?
I washed up here.
Oh, it must be some two weeks ago now.
We were in rough seas and when a wave hit us broadside I was jostled overboard and swept away.
I don't have room on board for you, mister.
I have scrap.
I thought my crew would have come to find me by now, but yours is the first ship I've seen pass by here.
Did the boy send you looking for me?
No.
Oh, well, I'm sure they're out there looking anyway.
Can you get me to Little Morrow, stranger?
I should be able to catch them there when they stop by next.
Yes.
Oh, yes, yes.
Sorry buddy, you're going to have to...
Oh, you're just going to leave me here to starve to death?
Curse you.
I'll be back.
It was like a destiny.
It was like a divine... You know what?
We lost that and not the research parts.
Uh-oh.
It's getting dark though.
OK, we gotta go.
We gotta go, gotta go.
Oh gosh, wait.
I don't want to lose the research parts.
This is...
Where am I?
Wrong way?
Heading the right way.
Do you think we can make it to...
Steel Point?
Remember Haste.
But we lose part of our boat, no?
Beware of overheating.
Little Morrow is closer.
Hold on.
Planet Mike, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Speed.
Oh, I see how it works now.
OK.
I thought it was gonna destroy our ship.
I see how it works now.
OK, OK.
And this is where he needs to go anyway.
So we're fine.
Hohohohoho.
The sweet rank smell of civilization.
I think the rank smell is you, buddy.
I thought I could never miss it.
He turns to you.
For someone who has just been saved, he seems gloomy.
I've not got much on me, as you can imagine.
And I have a feeling this isn't worth much anymore, for me at least.
But perhaps it'll be worth something to you.
He removes a signet ring from his left hand and presses it.
It's yours.
It's emblazoned with a symbol of a captain's wheel.
Sounds fancy.
On to better horizons, friend.
Farewell.
OK.
Wait, can we sell this?
What am I getting?
Oh, he gave me a book.
Nice.
90 bucks.
Wait, should I sell this?
The ship's wheel sigil is emblazoned proudly on this ring.
Such a symbol is sure to bring good luck to any captain that holds it.
Sell?
It's just loot?
Is it actually?
Keep it?
I can't tell.
Some people are saying keep it and some people are saying it's loot.
It's fine to sell.
It doesn't do anything.
OK.
I feel like if it did something it would tell us, right?
Well, no going back now.
OK.
That was so scary.
But now I understand how the...
What's it called?
The haste.
I thought it was like actively going to destroy our ship.
What's the painter?
Ah, the fisherman.
I thought you might stop by.
Welcome to my humble studio.
If you're wanting to experiment with some decorations, yes, I'm the person to talk to.
What sort of decorations?
I can attach flags and bunting to add some style to your boat.
I have a design here already that you might like.
If you find any others on your travels, bring them back to me and I can rig them up for you.
Of course I can also add a splash of color to your whole...
I'm sorry to say that my selection of pigments limited at the moment though.
How can I find more pigment?
He thinks.
The other day down by the shoreline I saw a strange crab with the most strikingly vibrant coloration.
My knees aren't suited to clambering over rocks and chasing crustaceans, you see.
But if you caught such a creature...
He clears scraps of cloth and paper from his workbench, revealing a large pester and mortar.
With the right binding agent we can grind them together for a new mixture.
He turns back to you.
A cunning plan formed in his mind.
This is kind of morbid.
Fisherman, bring me some of those strange crabs.
Okay.
For now, what can I help you with?
I want to paint my boat.
We're going to paint the roof.
What color?
Wait, is this the crab?
Crab!
We could do a sharp mint, but we need the strange crabs.
Oh man.
Let's do skewy green and see how it looks.
Oh, it looks like throw-up.
Much better.
Where?
Hold on, let's try...
Blue depth.
Oh, there's another page.
Hold on.
I like that.
Hold on, what other colors do you have?
Next page.
Maple, orange, royal purple, golden treasure, black abyss.
Let's do the hole.
And we'll do it blue depth.
Do you guys see a difference?
I don't see a difference.
I want crab.
No.
I don't see a difference.
Okay, thank you sir.
Wait, can I change my...
Let's see.
Let's do a fish flag.
Cute!
And...
A bunting.
Bunting on.
Bunting off.
What's the difference?
I don't see a difference.
Sharpen into my Yoshi.
What's bunting?
I don't know.
I don't see a difference.
We'll put it on though.
What are you doing here?
We already know.
Splash of color.
Alright, bye bye.
It's 2 AM.
I think we should sleep.
Okay, now before we venture off...
Spooky, spooky, mysterious creature of the night.
Bidet.
Lumpy mackerel.
He's so gross.
Nice.
Let's go...
Let's go sell this to this guy.
Okay.
Read the flavor text.
A writhing mass of lumps, twisting and pulling their way under the scales of their vessel.
How long can it have lived like this?
Since yesterday.
Probably.
I will voice what is on everyone's mind.
More whispers.
I got a mutant!
There you go.
He takes the berated fish from you.
He clutches it close to his chest, wringing his hands around its slimy body.
Yes, this should do nicely.
Here's what the fish is worth.
And why don't you take these...
You were swimming in research.
It sounds like the faintest whispering.
You listen.
Silence.
In the stillness of the room, the fishmonger's hands begin to tremble.
His face grows anguished.
Please, sell what you need and leave.
I must deal with this creature quickly now.
I got nothing.
See ya.
The fishmonger's door slams behind you.
You hear the heavy scraping of a metal bar sliding across it.
We've been locked out!
Maybe.
Okay, we got four research parts.
Refined outboard engine.
But I don't think we even have...
Actually...
I don't think... do we?
Oh, I guess, kind of, we have the space for that.
Yeah, we have the space for that, actually.
We'd have to sell our other two, but...
Or we could get this one.
Twin prop engine.
This engine is outfitted with a dual propeller system, increasing speed.
High quality components and excellent craftsmanship.
A reliable engine trusted by seafarers.
This one's just cheaper.
Super engine top, right?
This one?
I don't have enough.
Relatively new design.
This unit propels water through the system more efficiently than outboard propeller setups.
Save one more.
Is this one that good?
Yeah?
It's the best engines per block.
Oh, because it's nine by four.
Sorry, you have 9.5 and then you have four slots.
I'm doing math.
9.5 times four.
38.
And then this one is 36.8.
Is it that much of a difference?
I masked.
Plus it fits the eddy configuration.
Later on, yeah?
Okay.
I'll hold off on pots for now.
I guess I'll hold off on this too.
So...
Storage, storage, storage, storage...
Storage... Wait!
Oh yeah, that's right.
I was like, when did I get injured?
I wonder when.
I gotta make some money though.
We gotta make more money.
I can do this light space.
Yeah, which is actually good because we need that, no?
Oh wait, it's a scrap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, light and storage is good.
I did...
Modifies four rod spaces to also hold nets.
Okay, that's why we haven't unlocked nets yet.
But now we can get this bad boy.
Oh, I have to get uninstalled.
And installed.
And I can at least sell this probably.
Actually, I'm gonna hold on to it for now unless if our setup changes for some reason.
Should be fine though.
Uninstall, uninstall.
Gale Cliffs.
What did I just do?
Remove.
Gale Cliffs.
That's south?
So this way?
No.
Yes.
We're going beyond.
Is it bad if I use haste too much?
Will that do anything?
Markers on the compass.
I don't see any.
Spam it?
Okay.
Okay,
so this way.
Just let it cool down.
Got it.
Got it, got it, got it.
Thank you guys for helping me out.
I really appreciate it.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Little tiny island.
I think we can explore this real quick.
There's like a little something here.
Wait, is that it?
Yeah, I see it.
Land ho!
Okay, don't crash.
You pull up to a wreck with a familiar looking hull.
It's almost identical to the ship given to you by the mayor.
Except this one has a huge breach on one side.
You're tied up alongside the old wreck.
Look in the cabin.
Check the cupboards and drawers.
They've been completely and methodically emptied.
All the drawers are missing.
You're in the cabin.
Loose floorboard.
There are no floorboards left.
You're in the cabin.
Electrical equipment is still there, though surely exposure to the elements has fried the internals.
You angle the overhead radio down to get a closer look.
A note slips.
You're in the cabin.
Check out the cargo.
Is this an engine?
Oh, I can't take it down.
18.9 No, still ours together is better.
And a coastal ride.
I'm going to take this and we can sell it.
Oh, but it adds us... nevermind.
It adds two hours.
Nevermind, nevermind.
Oh, to storage!
Thank you, guys.
To storage, to storage.
It's going to say it adds like two hours.
I don't want to do that.
There's something over there, too.
Goodness gracious, there's so much to explore.
What is this?
I'm dredging, I'm dredging, I'm dredging.
It's like... I like that it's a rhythm game.
Ouroboros flag!
Uh-oh!
Time to go, time to go, time to go, time to go.
Time to go, time to go, time to go.
It's our time to go.
And I'm docked.
That was so scary.
Normal ocean things.
Let's see.
But our dog keeps digging them up and eating them.
I can't raise the subject without spoiling the surprise.
Can you bring me an aged conger eel?
Yes.
You'll be decently compensated.
She looks rich, so I think we will be.
Anything else?
Where can I catch one?
They can be tricky to find.
I'm told they inhabit the holes and burrows within the cliffs themselves.
Imagine they've been fished out of the edges, so you may have to venture into the passageway of the cliffs to find them.
She should give me the doggies.
What is the dog gonna do for me?
They only come out at night.
I do believe they hide during the day.
Good luck.
Anything else?
What can you tell me about the cliffs?
Many years ago, the cliffs used to be a haven for smugglers and pirates.
Legend tells of two pirate lords who used gale cliffs as their hideout.
Supposedly, they got into some disagreement and a huge battle was fought around the south side of the cliffs.
There certainly are a large number of wrecks in that area.
It's a good travel partner.
They would eventually be able to fight things for me.
Probably.
Some sailors might have used an eyepatch to keep one eye adjusted to the darkness.
Are you telling me...
to be a pirate?
Boss.
Snake.
Arrgh.
I'm Pirate Snake.
Oh.
Liquid.
I'm Sea Shanty Snake.
Arrgh.
I'm Sea Water Snake.
Shanty karaoke win.
I don't know.
I don't know any.
Both sides were completely destroyed.
Their treasure hordes left abandoned and unclaimed to this day.
I dare say they'd be worth a lot if anyone knew where to find them.
Anything else?
Any odd characters around this part?
Have you heard the tale of Magran?
He was an old whaler from these parts.
As the whales got more scarce, the crew spent longer and longer at sea trying to find them.
Magran, it seems, wasn't cut out for this.
What do we do with a drunken Minto?
What do we do...
Oh, is this a shanty?
Scurvy Snake!
As the whales got more...oh, it seems Magran wasn't cut out for this.
He formed an unnatural attachment to a scroll he found on one of these trips.
He says the scroll told him how to become immortal by eating mutated fish.
People started calling him Magran the Fishman.
One day, the town awoke to find all the boats, nets, and lines had been slashed in the night.
And old Magran was nowhere to be found.
Nor has he been seen since.
Uh-oh.
You don't think...
You don't think that's our fishman, right?
Where can I sell my fish here?
We catch our fish ourselves here, so we don't have much need for buying any.
But there's a merchant that travels around.
She's usually anchored across the bay and buys and sells almost anything.
She does repairs too.
Oh, nice.
Nothing.
We're gonna talk to the whaler?
What is it?
Uh, any shipwrecks?
The real wreck here is... around here is the settlement at Gale Cliffs.
For doubloons.
My brother ditched us and moved on over to those cliffs years ago.
Ugh, sorry.
I suspect he's regretting his decision now, the devil.
Anything else?
Any strange things in the area?
Some time ago, just after the last whale was brought in, there was a sudden exodus from Gale Cliffs.
What the heck is Gale Cliffs?
Dozens of ships sailed past, packed up and hurrying away north as fast as they could.
They were waving and shouting something at us from their boats, but we couldn't make it out.
Never did see or hear of them since.
Hey, what can you tell me about Ingfell?
One Chris Z said, welcome to membership, thank you!
C...P...
Yeah.
Ingfell used to be a whaling town.
Emphasis on the used to be.
We would go out, bring in a carcass and then the rest of the town would get to work.
But the whales got scarce some 20 years ago.
And look at us now.
Barely scrapping by for a new candle.
Can we eat?
I wanna know what they told them though.
Why did they leave?
Okay, so...
This is... Okay, we are at the Gale Cliffs.
How mysterious.
I saw the light coming from over there.
The spooky light, so...
Artifact manifest.
Oh wait, I see it?
Oh my gosh.
Are these things common here?
Is it not gonna chase after me?
Maybe not.
I got a black mouth salmon.
It chased after before.
More salmon.
I'm guessing this is the lady that sells?
Or buys?
They chase at night.
I see, I see.
I heard something strange.
Hello?
I'm docking?
I feel like we just finally have reached the game.
You know what I mean?
Ahoy there!
You're a new face.
A fisherman I take it?
Perfect!
Well, we should get along like a house on fire!
I call it chapter 2.
Yeah, that's fair.
I feel like we've done the prologue this whole time.
I'm a traveler and a merchant.
All rolled into one.
If you have any fish to sell, I'll take them on board and sell them at the next town I come across.
Likewise, I haul a small cargo of equipment between places.
You're welcome to peruse the stock and see if there's anything that takes your fancy.
Well, fish market.
I'm selling my fish.
Like I said, we need more money.
Have you met the photographer?
She stopped by my pontoon a little...
The photographer!
Someone mentioned that earlier.
Funny how earlier she said, I think we basically have the whole game unlocked.
She's loaded up with fancy camera equipment to take pictures of all the wildlife.
She sighs wistfully.
I wish I had my own camera.
Wouldn't it be nice to document everything you do?
You'd never forget anything.
Anyway...
She said she was setting up on a small island to the south of the morrows.
If you're in the area, maybe you should check on her.
What else you got?
Nothing new!
Just kidding.
Refined metal.
I can buy research parts.
Interesting.
And dry docks.
Oh, so I can upgrade here too.
Okay.
At least we saw that.
Let's check out the cliffs a little.
We also have in here...
This is the creepy...the creepy...
The creepy creepy.
Wait.
Can I get in here?
A pile of loose debris.
Clearing this would take some strong explosives.
Okay.
We can't do that yet.
Let's go in here.
It's a little...
Reverse reverse!
Reverse!
Keep going!
I'm in trouble!
No!
We might be on fire just a little bit.
I'm gonna waste all my money repairing the ship.
That was not good.
I shouldn't have looked back.
I didn't mean to.
Well, no.
I did mean to look back to see if he was following me.
Yeah, I shouldn't have looked back.
You're right.
Can you repair me?
How do you repair?
The shipyard.
I see, I see.
Thank you.
We didn't lose anything though.
I'll look around a little bit more before we sleep.
Is that thing just circling the island?
Killer whales!
They're so cute!
What if I get kinda close?
I should head back.
Sorry.
Oh, I read it.
Nice.
Check cabin for bonuses.
Now we get 10% resilience to panic.
I mean that actually.
I mean that actually!
Let's dock.
We'll dock over down here.
Well, I know I need explosives.
Which I do not have.
So it's kinda stinky.
I got a black sea bass.
More sea bass.
Talk to the merchant.
I will!
I will.
Depleted.
So far, OK.
So far, so good.
Now I can sell these.
We can at least make a little bit of money.
I didn't make my money back, but you know.
What does she want?
You need help with anything?
Assistance from an angler?
Absolutely.
I've been trying to collect records of where each species of fish is located.
Figured out most of them on my travels so far, but there are a few I haven't been able to track down.
Reckon you could share your info with me?
Sure!
Oarfish, gulper eel, goliath, tigerfish, coelacanth.
Oh gosh.
OK.
I know a little about each species already, so maybe I can point you in the right direction.
I will ask about this later.
Because I'm gonna get out of this area, so we'll come back.
Actually, maybe they might be in an area that...
Gale cliffs, OK.
Deepest depths imaginable, yes.
Specialist gear, OK.
Murky swampy waters, OK.
Primordial field, OK.
OK.
It's a long quest.
Yeah, I could gather that.
Yeah.
So.
We're at the gale cliffs.
Twisted strand, devil's spine.
Everything else sounds terrifying.
I'm trying to pillage, but I'm dummy thick and the clap of my peg legs keeps alerting the scallywags.
Wait.
Let's try going to maybe...
Stellar basin.
For now.
I wanna upgrade things more before I go back into the scary cliffs.
They were so scary.
Stellar basin is to the west.
This...
This way!
Yay!
And we'll catch any fish we see along the way, perhaps.
We're sailing the ocean blue.
It's just me and you.
There's nothing to do.
So I'm just gonna keep singing through.
OK.
When it turns red it gets a little freaky, no?
Where are all the fish?
Where are all the fish at?
It's more like this way, no?
Wait.
Fish spotted!
Blue mackerel.
Such an average fish.
Am I going the right way?
No.
This way.
Yeah.
Past these islands.
Wish there were some tunes we could listen to.
It's awfully quiet.
Where'd the music go?
I don't know, I think the game thinks that like we're...
We're in the spooky lands or something.
Did I see a sparkly?
No, I don't think so.
Oh!
There we go.
Looking around.
Is that a whole village?
Sorry, I know I keep checking the map.
I don't want to get lost.
I'm scared.
Keep dredging DLC where you fish up old records.
Wait, is that an actual thing?
Oh wait, uh oh.
It's time to get dark.
Can we make it to the dock?
On this side, right?
Yeah, yeah.
It's dark and I don't know where I'm at.
I'm lost and I'm scared.
Oh, there's jellyfish.
I'm guessing they're evil.
They're probably evil, right?
They're most likely evil.
A dock!
Are they coming for me?
I feel like something is coming for me.
Is something coming for me?
I can't tell.
This is a dock, right?
Ok, yeah.
Is that guy coming for me?
No, he's leaving me alone.
That's right, we got another message in the bottle.
It's so pretty, no?
What if we docked?
Alright, watch this.
We're gonna dock, it saves.
We're gonna undock.
If we die, it was worth it for the science.
Is that a tentacle or...
I think this...
See, it's fine.
Oh, what is that?
I don't have this.
I don't...
She's not gonna get mad if I go the long way.
Go further?
You want me to die?
I'm going the long way.
Probably.
I do kinda wanna see what a...
What a death is like.
Can I dredge here?
Don't get me please.
Don't get me.
I got a ring.
That looks fancy!
This side.
Where's the spooky...
What was that?
I'm scared.
Mother base!
What's that sound?
I don't know.
Where is...
The thing that we need to collect?
It's not in the middle, no?
I like that you can see the lighthouse even all the way from here.
You saved, right?
I mean I did, yeah, but like...
You know stuff is messed up when...
When your lights go out.
It was over here, no?
Research outpost.
I thought I saw it.
But it disappeared.
Oh!
Hello.
You're here too?
I have a seven dollar fish.
It's the big red evil thing.
I know, but I didn't see it.
Did you?
Oh!
I saw it, but then...
I saw it like over here, but then it disappeared, no?
Is this thing still gonna get mad at me?
It's in the middle.
This thing?
No way.
Hello!
Excuse me.
Oh, you're angry now.
Hello, I'm here for...
I died.
How do I get...
These look like some interesting fish.
A barracuda.
I should've waited.
Barracuda.
This game is so fascinating.
I think I'm gonna call it here.
I'm starting to get a little sleepy.
I think I'll call it here.
RW Bladewing!
Thank you for the support!
Finally caught a minstrel.
Also, people will tell you this is a fishing simulator.
But it's actually going to be a sleep simulator.
Yippee!
I can't wait to go to sleep.
Wait, so it really is the thing in the middle?
I wish that I could look around while I...
while I boot.
You know what I mean?
Wait, is it this?
I'm dredging.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Hold on man!
Hold on!
Nevermind.
Spyglass!
Oh you're so smart.
Mysterious fish.
Barracuda.
What's that?
Mysterious fish everywhere.
I can't get that.
Wait.
Can't get that either.
I don't see it!
What's even over here?
Sorry, I know I said I was going to end, but I really like this game.
We're in the Stellar Basin.
We're looking for a ring in the Stellar Basin.
A ring.
Different from that ring?
Is that the...that's not the ring I got before, is it?
Stellar, Stellar Basin.
Star Cries!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
Maybe we attempt...
to get it.
That ring.
We attempt to get it, maybe.
Welcome, welcome raiders.
I'm playing Dredge and it's really fun.
We're pirating.
I don't think I'll get mad here, right?
What's this?
This is also a ring.
Excuse me.
If I like, very chill, very...there we go.
Eeries!
No.
Is there a dog?
Like, is it that?
Oh gosh, is it the stuff in the middle?
I feel like it's gotta be in the middle.
No?
I feel like they would do that.
There it is!
Wait.
It's that, but we need the other...
I see it.
It is in the middle.
I saw it.
I didn't think you were lying, I just...
wanted to confirm.
You know, I just wanted to see with my own two eyes.
I will miss you.
I'm not going anywhere!
I'm staying.
What's this?
Okay, after this.
Strong explosives.
Okay, we need explosives for multiple things.
Okay, we have...oh my god.
I just...
I was up on it.
Up on my ship.
We're gonna...I'm gonna fish.
Coral group.
Oh, this thing is huge!
Here we go.
I'm gonna go sell this and then I'm done.
For real.
I will miss Minto when she ends stream.
Really?
I think I occupy enough of your thoughts that you don't miss me at all.
Maybe...
My hat grows.
My hat grows!
Otsumito everybody!
Thank you for hanging out with me with the drudge!
This is a lot of fun.
Oh my gosh, this game is so crazy!
But I hope you had fun too!
I...honestly...okay, so...
Sorry, I didn't mean to get bigger.
Oops, sorry.
I didn't mean to get...sorry.
Oops.
Thank you Bearlet for the superchat.
I...
I...I...
I was like, you know...
This week I'm gonna choose two chill games.
Because I have three kind of stressful games.
With like DMC and Metal Gear and...
And...
Repo?
I think that's a stressful game.
I don't know anything about it.
I just know it's the hot stuff right now.
I haven't...I have purposefully not watched anything about it.
You're so obsessed with us you can't help but get closer, huh?
No!
It's lethal company but silly.
Yeah, that's what I've heard.
So...
But then I played Astro Bot and that's...
I thought that was gonna be really chill but the levels ended up being so difficult.
I thought they were gonna be easy peasy levels but they were so hard.
And then this game also scared me.
I don't think I chose a single chill game at all this week.
Actually, no, this was pretty chill.
I'm happy about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But Otsumito everybody, thank you for hanging out with me.
And I'll see you guys when I see you next time.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Fushigi Sunday.
Oh yeah, that will be pretty chill.
Oh, thanks for reminding me.
Actually I have to post something about that.
I have to post something about that.
OK!
Otsumito itterasshai!
Everybody have a good day, have a good night.
And I'll see you later!
Thank you so much for the feed!
Thank you, thank you.
Bye bye!